Your office looks really nice.
Where do you work, Mary?
I work in a building downtown.
It's in the city center, so it can be really busy outside.
How about you?
Where do you work?
I work in a quiet part of town.
It's outside the city, but it's very near our house.
Do you work with some of your friends in the neighborhood?
Yes!
I work with my best friend here,...
...but I'm actually moving to the city next month.
Are you?
Yes.
I will be transferred to a different department, and their office is in the city.
Have you been there?
I have been there once.
It's a huge space, and the design is very modern.
There must be a lot of people working there.
There are five departments and each has their own room.
I heard there are three conference rooms,...
...a huge common space, and a cafeteria.
I see.
Well, we should meet when you move to the city.
Sure!